ladies and gentlemen Zac Efron and Best
Supporting Actress nominee Anna Kendrick
here the nominees for best sound editing
Christopher boys and Gwendolyn Yates
whittle for avatar Paul NJ audison for
The Hurt Locker
Wiley statement for Inglourious Basterds
Mark stek injure and Alan Rankin for
Star Trek Michael Silver's and Tom
Meyers for up
and the winner is Paul and Jay Addison
for The Hurt Locker
this is the first Academy Award and
third nomination for Paul and Jay
Addison he's also nominated tonight in a
sound mixing category
is such a great honor to be here yeah 23
years ago and while this other world I
sold everything I had to come and be
part of what you guys do over here it's
such a great honor
yeah not so many people of faith in me
and gave me cha shot at maybe when I
didn't I don't know that I earned it yet
and thank you to all those people there
my wife and my son for always loving me
no matter what
yeah Catherine what one incredible movie
thank you for everything in your
friendship all of you Academy thank you
so much
here are the nominees for best sound
mixing avatar Christopher boys Gary
summers Andy Nelson and Tony Johnson The
Hurt Locker Paul and Jay Addison and Ray
Beckett inglorious basterds Michael
Minkler Tony Lombardi and markula know
Star Trek Annabelle Mayer Andy Nelson
and Peter J Devlin Transformers Revenge
of the Fallen Gary P Russell Gary
summers and Joffrey Paterson
and the winner is The Hurt Locker all
empty odds and Ray Beckett
this is the second Academy Award tonight
and third nomination for Paul and Jay
Addison this is the first Academy Award
a nomination for Ray Beckett
say something
again thank you so much
and it's a little embarrassing and to
quote Catherine say spores of riches
this ray apart thank you for the Academy
this is the crowning achievement of my
career thank you to Catherine the whole
production team thank you to my team in
Jordan
Simon bish and BA Hortman and thank you
all thank you